tu aurais envie de faire une surprise
comme vous savez les faire mais là c'est
une vraie vraie belle surprise et des
personnes qui ont tenues spécialement à
vous remercier pour la gentillesse que
vous avez accordé une fois de plus et
regarder parce que franchement là c'est
qui c'est mais c'est mehdi c'est fort
non regardez regardez ce qui se passe
mais
là
tu as promis
tous les vendredis sur tpb
tous autour de la table tous ensemble
pour qui fait ses marques à baba nous
faut tous délirer mais c'est pour ça que
ce soit j'ai oublié mon couple est alors
du coup en patates explique jean train
d'agoniser
qui décide pour tenir moi jamais
t'oublier
encore
tuez pas
or
msa
palavas avinel d'archivés merci d'être
là contente de voir
merci beaucoup bien sûr bercé les chéris
merci merci j'étais venu je sais et
boxes un mot pour tout le monde et si sa
chérie c'est vrai que vous avez reste de
la coopération
merci merci je me demandais ce que je
faisais là ça va merci merci beaucoup
alors il ya tout le monde a l'air si
elle souhaite surtout mon gars idée
fihri merci aux aides de la coopération
merci merci bien sûr à un média handicap
pour norma sébastien proyart accueil qui
était vraiment à l'initiative de ce
projet tous les vendredis et les cherry
pour signer avec moi à la rentrée 2008
pour le vendredi ou pas merci merci mon
chéri ça va comme beaugas toujours tu
select - 2018 j'ai fait les chéris je
voudrais vous remercier et je voulais
vous dire pour moi vous êtes vraiment
exceptionnelle dans l'émission à chaque
fois que vous venez et vous qui nous
regardent et bardé nous rejoindre parce
que tous les vendredis c'est ouvert à
tous tes pmp je suis très très touché
parce que tu as fait dans son soigneur
seniors vincent giner au patronat
si un constat